bonjour à tous aujourd'hui une vidéo un
petit peu spécial comme on dit puisque
je vais vous parler d'un nouveau projet
auquel je participe une nouvelle chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle billes de science
alors petite particularité contrairement
ce que vous imaginez sans doute je ne
vais pas vous demander d'aller vous
abonner à cette chaîne
la seule chose que j'aimerais que vous
fassiez c'est de parler de cette chaîne
ou d'envoyer le lien à tous les
enseignants et les enseignantes que vous
connaissez notamment en maternelle et en
primaire
car c'est à eux que cette chaîne
s'adresse le but de la chaîne by de
science qui est une collaboration entre
plusieurs vidéaste et la fondation la
main à la pâte
c'est de présenter des expériences et
des activités pédagogiques scientifiques
que les enseignants peuvent proposer en
classe à leurs élèves ce sont des
activités organisées selon les principes
de ce qu'on appelle la démarche
d'investigation ont fait expérimenter
les élèves en leur soumettant un
problème en leur demandant d'imaginer
des expériences et de les réaliser eux
mêmes
l'idée de cette chaîne c'est d'aider les
enseignants à proposer ce type
d'activités scientifiques en classe
notamment en primaire puisque c'est un
âge où les enfants sont de vrais petits
scientifiques en herbe et ne vivent pas
encore la science comme une matière
difficile ou bien qui va servir à faire
de la sélection
alors je ne vous en dis pas plus allez
voir la chaîne si vous êtes curieux mais
surtout parlez-en aux enseignants que
vous connaissez parmi votre famille ou
vos amis envoyer leurs le lien qui est
en descriptions car l'idée c'est
vraiment d'en toucher un maximum pour
essayer d'aider à la place des sciences
à l'école je compte sur vous
[Musique]